essayez de nous deux qu'on diriger le
Rabaska quand on est en avant on a comme
tous
cette sortie sur la rivière des Prairies
est très spéciale mais ces élèves de 6e
année ont tout de même l'habitude d'être
dehors il profite régulièrement de
l'enseignement en plein air temps pour
l'éducation physique que pour les
matières de base pour la nature on
découvre plus le monde comme on peut
travailler avec le soleil c'est comme
plus confortable c'est plus amusant à
travailler dehors que dans la glace
c'est cool de faire de plein à l'école
parce que là parce qu'on bouge pas trop
à l'école on sort dehors manger dans des
parcs comme ça il faut apprendre à pas
polluer etc etc mais ça nous ça nous
apprend la vie et tout
leur école dispose d'une flotte de vélo
également de raquettes pour l'hiver
mais surtout leurs enseignants croient
au bienfaits de l'apprentissage à
l'extérieur
quelques études internationales ont
révélé les effets positifs notamment sur
la tension et sur la réduction du stress
est-ce que l'apprentissage pleinaire
améliore les habitudes de vie des
enfants c'est là vraiment la première
étude québécoise a deux reprises l'an
dernier les chercheurs ont comparé deux
groupes de sixième année de deux écoles
similaires dans le Grand Montréal l'une
des deux offre l'enseignement en plein
air sur une base régulière pendant une
semaine les élèves ont porté un
accéléromètre et puis ils ont répondu à
un questionnaire à la fin de la semaine
donner à l'appui l'étude conclut que les
élèves du programme plein air bougent
plus que les autres au récréations et se
rapproche ainsi des recommandations
quotidiennes les enfants qui participent
aux activités d'apprentissage plein air
top le 60 minutes donc ça permet aux
garçons d'arriver au 60 minutes
recommandées et qu'est-ce qui est très
intéressant c'est cet effet là et
davantage
prononcé chez les filles et c'est
important parce que c'est les filles qui
s'éloignent le plus du 60 minutes
recommandé d'activités physiques ce
n'est peut-être pas encore l'antidote
l'abus du temps d'écran mais l'étude
révèle que les élèves qui profitent de
l'école dehors sont plus raisonnables
dans leur temps de loisirs chez les
enfants qui faisaient de l'apprentissage
en plein air mais on a eu une réduction
ou plutôt une stabilisation de la
progression de du temps d'écran je sors
plus souvent que d'habitude pour sortir
avec mes amis jouer dehors
ce sont des résultats qui donnent envie
aux chercheurs de mesurer les effets à
plus grande échelle mais aussi
d'encourager les enseignants qui de plus
en plus sont nombreux à sortir de leur
classe faudrait pouvoir les écouter qui
deviennent des diffuseurs de toute cette
approche-là qui est somme toute un peu
nouvelle dans notre dans notre province
on a de la
chance les élèves veut ne sont plus à
convaincre ici à Louise despaty
Radio-Canada Montréal
[Musique]